Miguel you asked an interesting question
about the future of civilization itself
Nikolai Kardashev a Soviet the
astrophysicist in the 1960s was
frustrated trying to analyze signals
from intelligent life in outer space
what are we looking for so he began to
rank civilizations on a scale of type 1
type 2 type 3 a type one civilization is
truly planetary they absorb all the
light coming in from their mothers star
and they control all planetary forms of
energy for example they might be able to
modify the weather they may not be able
to control earthquakes and volcanoes
that's type 1 a type two civilization is
stellar they control the entire energy
output of a star type 3 is galactic they
control the energy output of the entire
galaxy now to put things into
perspective Flash Gordon or Buck Rogers
would be would be living in a type one
civilization where they control all
forms of planetary energy they can
simply rock it anywhere on the planet
Earth at ease
type 2 might be Star Trek the Federation
of Planets has only colonized a few
neighboring planetary systems they can
barely manipulate the energy output of a
single star so the Federation of Planets
would be type 2 but even Captain Picard
and and William Shatner live in fear of
a type 3 galactic civilization and that
is the Borg or the Empire of the Empire
Strikes Back or the aliens of
Independence Day they would be truly
galactic in scope able to harness the
energy of black holes for example and
there might even be type 4 type 4 which
is extra galactic for example on Star
Trek we have the Q the Q might be a
candidate for a time for civilization
now what are we on the scale we are type
0 that's where we rate we get our energy
from dead plants oil and coal now Carl
Sagan tried to refine it a bit he
estimated that we're actually about a
point 7 if you are a point 7
civilization that means you are about a
years from attaining type 1 status this
means we can see evidence of this
everywhere we go the Internet is the
beginning of a type 1 telephone system
we're privileged to be alive to witness
the beginning of a telephone system of
the next hundred years the European
Union is the beginning of a type 1
economy why do we even have the European
Union of course these countries hate
each other
they've been warring with each other for
thousands of years ever since the ice
melted in Europe why are these countries
these mortal enemies ganging together to
form the European Union well to compete
with us and who are we we are NAFTA so
we're seeing the beginning of gigantic
global trading bloc's English will
probably be the planetary language you
can go anywhere in the planet Earth and
the educated already speak English they
are bilingual and on the internet the
number one language on the Internet is
English followed by Mandarin we're
seeing the beginning of a planetary
culture everywhere you go you see rock
and roll you see Gucci bags you see high
fashion you see a very similar global
culture a culture of high fashion
Hollywood glitz rock-and-roll blue jeans
that same kind of culture youth culture
and the culture of the rich is now going
around the planet Earth you see the
beginning of planetary sports the
Olympics soccer games realize that in
the old days you had competition between
tribes tribal rivalries sometimes led to
Wars so they would have games between
them now we have games not just between
small provinces but games that envelop
the entire planet Earth now this doesn't
mean that the transition to type 1 is
going to be easy because there are
forces that are opposed to this
transition to a planetary civilization
look at nuclear proliferation the bomb
is proliferating to some of the most
dangerous unstable areas of the world
for example the Middle East not only
that but terrorism is fundamentally
based on living in a society opposed to
type 1 a type one civilization is
scientific
it is pluralistic it is multicultural it
is tolerant because it is global
however terrorists do not want to live
in that society they would rather live
in the year 1000 AD rather than in the
next century so I would say that we have
a hundred years to go before we attain
type 1 status it's not inevitable but
every time I open the newspaper I see
the birth pangs of type one every single
headline points to the birth pangs of a
type one civilization so when historians
of the future look back at the 21st
century they'll say well gee all the
crises of the 21st century it's obvious
there's a direction there's a pattern
the birth of a type one civilization